need to find other people who can own  their own p ls and become entrepreneurs  within your company and what happens is  it becomes a shift from being a business  to being a conglomeration and so if you  think about amazon they're not amazon's  not a business right it's a business of  businesses it's a collection of  businesses that serve a purpose right  and so i had to shift my thinking in  terms of how mine worked to we have a  number of business units that operate  off of one shared spoke of shared  services we've got it hr legal finance  all in the middle and then we've got  profit drivers that drive revenue across  the business units and the people who  drive those are responsible and  compensated based on the growth of their  business line or their product loan and  so then you get people who can start  making 300 grand 400 grand a year 500  grand a year if they crush it and they  should because otherwise they'll just  start their own version of your business